we need Lube hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to factory
oh hi Bob what's up everybody
hi okay so we made a lot of changes
since the last episode we're gonna go
over them real quickly first bob has a
big ol area up top to show off it's
pretty amazing
oh yeah yeah check out my enormous penis
hey guns I mean same thing really I mean
also you made the cold changes but also
we defended this area even though those
guns don't have any bullets in them
which is a problem but that's plenty of
defense because if we notice on the map
the pollution is just just starting to
tickle the nose hairs of that big
encampment up to the north so we don't
want to mess with them just yet so we
want to be protected when they start
attacking we're still a ways away from
the only not showing evolution that's
concerning
oh well it's tickling them and also we
got coal going to the others so coppers
now fully automated this other the steel
production is now automated almost fully
because coal still needs to go to the
other one I can probably fix that I
think I think I know how to fix it it
just needs a smart inserter only picking
out coal and putting it on the ends of
the steel furnaces oh no wait there's no
grabby into that so it would have to
aah that's a good question that's a
puzzle answer puzzle you're talking
about smarty pants I just getting the
the steel furnaces some coal but that's
precise I'm getting a steel furnace it's
called don't you worry yeah okay also
I'm gonna research construction robots
because we just got logistics robots
done so we can build logistics robots
somehow do that I don't know how to do
that also I fixed the power system I got
a new power system going over here
basically they just play hopscotch with
the coal so that they always get coal in
the boilers as is needed and then they
produce enough power as is needed so
that's that but that's not important
because right now we need all these are
about to run a mark huh logistics robots
logistics robots are in crafting also
there's something called a Robo port a
Robo port how I area 50 by 50 kids truck
Oh
45 advanced circuits what oh Jesus
Christ
ah we're gonna have to up our um
everything game I think we need we need
things making advanced circuits for us
they take three ingredients they take a
regular electronic circuits plastic bar
copper cable hot tits oh that's good
it's gonna be so easy okay but that's
fine because that's fun how do we make a
flying robot frame not even the
slightest idea oh god it's in
intermediate products it requires
electric engine battery steel plate
electronics sir it requires so much oh
how do we do that we need Lube we need
Lube Lube and lube and lube that's still
like I remember that joke you made like
Quaker Steak & Lube Lube but I don't
know how to make Lube oh wait we can
make Lube out of heavy oil so it's
already right here oh so I just changed
over over the heavy oil to instead of
solid fuel now it's doing um Lube okay
sounds good so we're making Lube that's
doing Lube stuff all right
Lubin it all up okay so that's on it
what six later wait what nothing nothing
well I I distinctly heard the word butt
sex I it's not no oh I forgot this isn't
a solid thing so now I need to pipe it
out of here we need to we need a storage
tank Bob your storage tank man we need
storage tank this [ __ ]
I'm storage tank man you were doing all
the storage tank before I guess that's
fair enough
that's that's true and everything I mean
I can't pull it out so it needs to be in
it we need to somehow get this lube into
our bodies so that we can carry it
somewhere else hmm
it's very scientific
but I don't know how to do that so I'm
assuming Nicole supplied the steel
furnaces finally it took me a while okay
good
but apparently like how do we get this
what do we do with Lube that we can make
it huh so we have to pipe it don't we
yeah because a liquid manage it
yeah but pipe it to where and how do we
I can't pull it out of the thing it's
just there so how do we craft with it if
we need Lube so flying robot frame
oh so we need a barrel intermediate
product empty barrel and then fill it
with ah stuff ah
we're aerial robot frame Oh God yeah
it's all the way on the right he needs
electric engines and electric engines
you need Lube a lot of [ __ ] a lot of
[ __ ] when you install Furyk acid which I
don't know how to get that oh my god
these like the engine units cannot be
crafted in by hand so you need an
assembly machine to make them what the
[ __ ] why what did we what did we do mark
what if we walk into this is horrifying
oh my god but we can do it maybe when I
get gates I want to build a gate that's
what I want to build that's simple I'll
just gate I don't know I don't handle
gate I don't know I don't know I don't
know oh my gosh mark we could research a
railway that will be so useful probably
okay oh oh oh that allows gates alright
I'm a researching military too
i'ma do Nguyen it do it do it up because
I'm gonna work my brain as hard as I can
to get this [ __ ] underway and you're
gonna come back 30 minutes later with
just my brain exploded out of my head
like out before we started this episode
it was like oh let's say well we got
everything set up and figured out
alright now we're ready let's just start
the episode we're ready to go ready to
go ready to go no problem ready to go
we did we did so well in the beginning
and then I don't I don't
I don't even know I don't even
understand it but I know that there's a
way to make empty barrels into what we
need so I'm going to try that first okay
do I just put I just put can I touch my
empty barrel to the story sake can I put
a story I'm literally touching the
storage barrel everywhere I can
it's not working yeah well okay I said
your one and only attempt I touch the
storage barrel on everything man
I really tried okay so it must be okay
it must be okay
it must be that now it has to go into a
different chemical plant that is for the
storing this of it so that when you do
that it will now do put ins into barrel
uh-huh uh-huh and then when you have
barrel in chemical plant it it will it
will put in barrel and you will have
barrel and barrel is what you have
barrel of oil yeah we'll get a 50 gallon
drum of Lube and then we'll have a good
time okay did that make sense yeah okay
good all right good
cuz I'm making criss crossing like pipe
systems that aren't logical in any
fashion but it's gonna work cuz I ran
out of space cuz of your walls and I
didn't want to break down the walls so I
literally am crossing everything over
pipe to underground hole even four walls
I haven't touched your beautiful they're
fine don't I didn't
don't I didn't if you do I will end you
I I really didn't I promise you I did
not I got really [ __ ] up this Cole
situation it's probably not as bad as I
[ __ ] up literally everything over here
so I think you're gonna be fine
ah damn it Phil crude barrel how do I
fill crude barrel oh I don't know they
don't understand
oh stop dinging me oh man I am like my
brain is not having right how do we do
this
made oh wait made made in assembly
machine okay so maybe maybe I have to
pipe it into an assembly machine okay
okay all right I'm gonna try that and if
I pipe it into an assembly machine maybe
then I can put the barrel in there and
have that make what I need it to make
got it yeah yeah okay okay so I don't
need this I don't need this but I do
need okay can can it pipe right into
there no you can't do that it can't pipe
it into a machine how do we do this
small pump whoo small pump you know me
don't yell at me I'm not yelling at you
wake up my fault oh is it I don't know
how do we lube don't know how to lube
I'm having my own problems don't yell at
me I'm not yelling at you what are your
problems what are you doing I'm too
stupid it's my name so it's not it's not
on the same level as yours it's not on
the same level we're not going to get
flying robots ever at this rate oh okay
okay it worked when I turn the assembly
machine into an engine processor it it
made a pipe attachment to it
Oh mmm okay so this is good that means
that it's now it now do have Lube in it
now it just needs electronic circuits
and normal engines and normal engines
are also made in machine holy [ __ ] it
wants me to make a loop I'm not ready to
make this loop
oh no I don't have enough space for this
loop Oh God Bob things are going very
poorly for me are they going anybody my
stuff is going just perfectly so I'm not
worried about it
something tells me that might be a lie
like that might know obviously uh it's
taking me like an embarrassing amount of
time to figure it out but it's going
just awesome yeah also apparently we're
we're under attack by something and I
don't know what what what no mommy so I
can kick goddamn while he's still out of
power fine if I'm gonna him we got the
other ones yeah but it's not enough to
power the whole base well let me allow
altair altair all these old steam
engines down and wreak or trigger them
into your configuration and then they'll
all be JC chained together that's
actually a good idea I like that that's
that's a then we'll have a bunch of open
space over here to where you can build
your new loop oh god your your stone
miners they're out of stone
we have no stoning now I need steps if
not more is there not more patches over
there or you could just sort of
reshuffle um let's see I don't know
there's no way they used up those old
stone patch the stone was very very
sporadic but there are more here I guess
I can I can work with this I can work
with it I just need some long grab it
grab ease and I'm gonna fix this
muhfucka [ __ ] have some steam
engine power so okay but the hole okay
no it's fine it's fine you're right it's
fine it's totally cool we got everybody
to know what your tired about no it's
fine it's fine don't worry about there's
actually plenty of stone in these chests
there's lots of stone it's cool it's
fine it's totally cool you don't need to
yell at me okay we are the same we're on
the same team it's like the evolution to
drunk minecraft just like June's sorry
no no no me man [ __ ] you
we were we were doing so good and then
we got shunted back to the Stone Age I
started again that started yay gay it's
doing it I got six more [ __ ] steam
engines
that man I'm not even done yet oh man
might as well go for broke yeah I'm
gonna set them all up [ __ ] it at least
four more cuz this setup is not idiotic
and it feeds itself and it's like oh wow
yeah exit what you said choose the
chugga chugga chugga chugga chug yeah
wait I don't know if that one water pump
is that one water pump enough I guess it
is holy [ __ ] that one offshore pumping
yeah
hot tits I guess you don't need a lot
and exploit water pumps are oh man
apparently yeah they all got tons of
water all I have two more steam engines
I was trying to make it symmetrical but
I'm out of steam engines dammit I'll
help you I will make two more and point
like that tah-dah oh it's so pretty
Wow look at that [ __ ] look at
that [ __ ] now that's gonna it
self-sustaining
oh god that's gonna bump up the
pollution ah yeah pump up the jams
pump it up something Jam nice and the
two cool things are more than enough oh
you got a third one up there okay that's
more than one up there it's a little
excessive I might take it back down and
so God you can get stuck in there holy
[ __ ] ok I'm trapped okay so that we're
gonna fast-forward through that because
that that won't count that was us being
stupid about having no now we fixed my
idiocy from last night at four in the
morning when I was playing this game
literally the idiocy we've been
tolerating for the past few nights
oh it's literally consistently holy
every episode there was so moments like
I'll pull more [ __ ] in the [ __ ]
but [ __ ] in it yeah there's literally a
fire in our ship that we're on and we're
like I should go put on the fire to
splash a bucket of water on it's fine
we'll get back to it later hurry up and
come back I don't even care we got to
work on more important [ __ ] like the
science machine that's all gobbed up why
is the science machine gobbed up whoo oh
I just got a bunch of science out of it
so who got dad who got this [ __ ]
literally just conveyor belts way too
many conveyor belts well I said it's
like it doubles as a convenient conveyor
belt machine so we never have to make
him ourselves
that one conveyor but it's just the one
conveyor belt literally [ __ ] anyway okay
so now that we got that ah man my
inventory is just loaded with it okay so
now uh Bob if you come up north you need
your help on this there I need help
there's no way I can do this by myself
um so got it sister here's the rub so
literally we have to make this assembly
loop near this refinery there's no other
way to get lube into this than pumping
it so that's the problem we need though
we should take over this forest to the
north of the refinery yes we should just
pipe the lube straight up this pathway
here 100% yes to this area I agree we
can do that
yeah but there'd be a whole terraforming
project sort of thing okay but until we
get the loop then I say we try to make
just one robot instead of making a whole
bunch of robots we should just make
enough machines down here that feed
themselves and then move it by hand into
this machine until we can make just one
robot so I need a a barrel for lubricant
yeah we're gonna need barrels and then
we need we got the lube we the only Lube
is needed an engine too and you only
need one engine to do that but we also
need batteries which needs sulfuric acid
so to make sulfuric acid that a chemical
plant yeah it's a chemical plant thing
that is made with water so there's a
lake right over there
so we can pump water from that this one
can make sulfuric acid can it oh you
need one yeah I need water so we just
need to punt there's a there's a lake
right there so we just need to I'm gonna
tear some of this water got some extra
pumps I think from dismantling the old
steam system nice okay so we just need
pipe and we need to get it there once
again this is all gonna be fast
forwarded [ __ ] because holy [ __ ] uh-huh
good god yeah so we're all right so the
I will start the offshore pump okay and
piping process to get the water over
here okay I'm just gonna make more
assembly machines and I'm gonna put
gaps in between so we can walk the whole
[ __ ] shenanigans over here man yeah
this is this is no joke this is like
serious factorio is what everyone was
like oh they're gonna get to this [ __ ]
and then [ __ ] every almost hardcore
factorial fans out there you know what
we're talking about yeah oh man
okay so hump and then so that's the [ __ ]
we're gonna have to pump sulfuric acid
into this - holy [ __ ] we're gonna just
need to make another refinery
oh really do I totally have underground
pipes yeah we got to make another
refinery or something okay so this needs
to be made here
it needs steel needs gears and it needs
oddly enough it needs pipe so I need to
make a whole bunch of pipe oh boy oh boy
oh boy this is gonna make it was that
really underground by Oh No okay there
you okay this is making an engine cool
so that's one part of it so the engines
then the batteries yeah we just need
copper plates and sulfuric acid wait
where do we get sulfur oh no a sulfur
comes from yeah sulfur comes from
petroleum and water so we need petroleum
pumping into a chemical plant okay let's
just feel I can just put water into this
word yeah exactly good 100% okay so I'm
gonna undo these cuz that's pointless
and like this that yeah you're Johnny's
my so now he can make sulfur um yes yes
making sulfur sulfur and then sulfur is
a solid perfect and then so sulfuric
acid is made in a chemical plant with
sulfur iron plate and water again so
split the water pipe into another
chemical plant
um do I need to just make a new chemical
plant yeah I might have one we want to
make it down here uh the water else with
the water south yeah I can do that get
kinda ground right there is that good
place [ __ ] rock you can shoot the
rock and it'll blow up okay this is now
making an electrical engine unit which
is
good okay we're making it it's happening
it's on my hand it's doing it now
then we just need another one making a
battery sure sure no actually no we make
battery by hand no batteries made in a
chemical plant what the hell hey I used
underground pipe so we can actually keep
the wall intact look at that nice well
done Hama Gabrus tricky I'm a I don't do
gamers I don't know what you're doing
but I feel like a genious
ok good job being a geek good gamer Asst
don't make fun of me I'm a gamer Asst so
now we have sulfuric acid
we need to pipe that out into another
assembly machine which there's two more
down there ok so I need to pipe this
into a in do wait no this assembly
machine way hang on a second battery can
this not make a battery this could make
a battery why can't I make a bet oh no
batteries are only made into oh it pumps
into another chemical plant ah ok I can
make one of those that pumps into
another chemical plant that makes
batteries there's a gap between those so
we can walk back and forth ok cool and
then plant it's almost done yeah this is
gonna be worth it when we make this one
robot and then realize that we don't
think that's gonna be a [ __ ]
he's gonna be our little buddy
kid that goes in there like break him
we're gonna like destroy this robot oh I
got your power got your power right
nevermind alright good job Bob
Brad yeah yeah okay and that's making
batteries yeah it's cool so do we just
need an extract at you from that I'm
just gonna take one out by hand and then
put it where it needs to go cuz I got
nothing better to do with my time
that also is a stat are-- ste need steel
can you go get more steel please yeah I
hope the steel stuff is still working I
think it should be yeah it's totally
working steel stuff like working over
here oh yeah is working work e whoo
any more electric circuit we're almost
there were almost there
oh my god I got so much steel I don't
even know what to do with it that's good
we need that much hey gates are finished
now I can build gates nice what do you
need where you need steel that just put
it in this flying robot frame the one on
the right middle right this one yeah
whoosh and that should start working as
soon as I put these in there
hey hey it's gonna make a river dream
here yeah yeah yeah yeah and then we can
just make a logistics robot which
transports between logistics chests
what's this what's a smart chest I've no
[ __ ] idea where do I mean if you if
you look at the tech tree there are
things called requestor chests or smart
delivery chests or all kind of [ __ ] we
need to research circuit network to get
smart chest parts that we can research
that are called algorithmic some such
nonsense
spider Combinator Oh God arithmetic
Combinator oh god constant Combinator
different colored wires not even I
didn't even you you don't we but I when
you when you see you but you do what
yeah then yeah this it's so complicated
man I imagine if we're trying to do this
efficiently yeah well if we were like
all right now wait before we build
anything yeah what configuration of
these buildings that we yeah and
processes that we have to could
facilitate I mean we did kind of box
ourselves in admittedly like it's a bit
of a problem we're gonna die man I
thought we were dead verily we're never
gonna die because everything's fine but
I got like 30 turrets and they've all
got some bullets in them it's fine but
what I just built was a robot yeah Diddy
haw is alive
yeah it's hang on let me try it I don't
know what make him do something make it
dance I just I can put
there it is there buddy
yeah where God oh I picked him up I'm
sorry I'm sorry
we made one he's our little Odie
yeah we have a friend the only other
friend we have on this horrible sounds
does he he's all ray you oh wow
oh my god click on him oh he does a
little radio noises ok so we did it guys
yay go us go team go okay so that's all
the time we have in this one next
episode we're gonna figure out how to
make more of these bad boys and get them
to go places it's hard enough getting
them I don't know how we're going yeah
it's not it's not move how do we it's
not moving it we don't have any smart
chests we just got the research for
smart chests but we'll get that in a
second so thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always we'll see you
next week oh here we go
just not perfect Oh